so good morning
tackling climate change and caring for
our environment
requires us to think the way we live
and this is why we have made
the european green deal our priority
we're taking the necessary steps one by
one to get there
and today it's the strategy for a
renovation wave
that will help us cut emissions and
reduce
energy poverty it will bring economic
social and environmental benefits
but the european green deal is way more
than that
it is a systemic change
and to achieve this we need a broad
engagement
we need wide support and we need
lots of imagination and
creativity behind it and this is why
we're
launching today the european bauhaus
the european bauhaus movement is
intended to be a bridge
a bridge between on one hand the world
of science
and technology and on the other hand the
world of arts
and culture it is about a new european
green deal aesthetics
combining the good design with
sustainability
the european bauhaus is about bringing
the european green deal
closer to people's minds and homes
and making tangible the comfort and the
attractiveness
of sustainable living
the european bauhaus will demonstrate
that the necessary can also be
beautiful the european bauhaus will be a
think and experimentation
space it will be a forum for discussion
for example
or an experimentation lab it will be an
accelerator for new solutions or a hub
for global networks
and experts it might be a discussion
space for citizens interested in the
topic
we will roll out the european bauhaus in
three stages
the first one is a design phase
to explore the ideas and to shape the
movement
and here we want to draw on the
expertise and the engagement of
many so be designers or architects
or artists or digital experts
scientists entrepreneurs students
engineers
you just name it everybody who wants to
take part with it is invited to come
the second stage will be
the delivery phase starting with
five european bauhaus projects
in different eu member states
all of them committed to sustainability
combined with arts and culture
and each adapted to the different local
conditions
and with specific focus such as for
example
natural building materials or
energy efficiency or
demographics future oriented mobility
could be one topic
or the resource efficient digital
innovation might lead
another one and finally
the third phase will be about spreading
the ideas
a european bauhaus vocation is to grow
and reach out beyond europe's border
so if europe is to lead the way
in the twin green and digital transition
we should engage in cultural debates as
well
and the new european bauhaus is part of
this broader vision we have
building the world of tomorrow that is
more sustainable more beautiful
more humane this is our goal
thank you
you